hello everyone and welcome back to the
first match of the semifinals of the
Magnus invitational it's Fabiano Caruana
vs. Hikaru Nakamura after four games of
the rapid the match the match was tied
and they now go into into a blitz mini
match now Fabiano lost the first blitz
game and this is the second one so
Fabiano again in a must-win situation he
has the white pieces will he be able to
force another blitz in mini match but
before we check that out I would just
like to congratulate and thank everyone
for joining the tournament yesterday and
here are the winners of yesterday's
tournament so first the meadow arena so
for the four players who are rated below
1700 these are the top ten with was up
Antonio new era 1000 and even ESCO
winning the tournament by winning top
three places and in the main event at
the Ivan Madar Friday arena we have be
stopped and gentlemen blue wolf
international naturally only white there
was 1908 and an 143 to pecky one
creative genius Bruno Parcher which are
above me hail 2002 and checkmater 47
with a blue wolf to surprising everyone
and finishing in first place ahead of
international natural only right so I
was a lot of fun and over 2,000 players
joined us so we'll see we'll see if we
can beat that next Friday so once again
thank you all for joining and you know
hope hope you get even better results
next time now getting back to the match
a Fabi opens with E 4 we have E 5 by
Nakamura 933 9th to c6 and Bishop to c4
Fabi again goes for the Italian and
there is something that Magnus mentioned
during the livestream that out of the
two of them he thinks that he Carlos
speaks better Italian and he goes for
Bishop to c5 the Joko piano and and this
time this time before the Evans gambit
was also not played which is a shame but
we have castles by Fabi and ok Knight to
f6 continuing with the Joko piano
we have d3 and now the standard yoko
piano star b6 we're c3h6 rook to e1 and
now just castles I will often mention
the Knight to g4 doesn't really do it
think since white is very happy with
rook to e2 so castles ending out h3 not
allowing anything to land on g4 we have
a five grabbing some space on the Queen
side also making room for the dark
square bishop on a7 if needed and now
Knight B to d2 the night is coming to f1
and later to g3 with Bishop to b6 not
allowing any breakthroughs to come with
an attack on the bishop and now tonight
the f1 we have Knight to e7
and now Knights to g3 so both players
just improving the positions over there
night and there is a one game in the
database for Knight to g6 was played but
here he car goes for Bishop to e6 and it
is as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so much of
characters on e6 we have F captors and
e6 and now just d4 so Bobby needs to win
to keep the natural life Hikaru is very
happy with a draw ECAD person before we
see captors in now only now Knight to g6
so Hikaru says my pieces are very well
placed you're the one who needs a win
you you do something so Bishop to e3
Bobby continues development and mount a
four by Nakamura we have Queen to c2 and
then out Queen to I ate
we have a three and then now b5 striking
in the center where Fabi can either
capture and play against the dis
isolated isa spawn which he doesn't like
instead he goes a five he grabs more
space in the center we have Knight to d7
and now Knight to d2 are preparing to
also start expanding with the f1 if
needed we have Bishop to a5 now pinning
that night as the rook is anyone and now
rook eat the c1 putting pressure on the
C file in here as the e5 pawn is
overloaded adjust c5 attacking the the
base of the pawn chain the defender of
the e5 pawn so here Bobby captures in
the now Nakamura just grabs the e 5.9 G
captures on e5 and rook back to F 1 we
have Knight back to FS tonight back to
c6 and all of a sudden it's Nakamura who
has the very strong Center and it's it's
questionable if Bobby will be able to
keep an eye on the c5 pawn so b4 here
either
the bishop to move all the way back or
what Nakamura did a capture some B 3
alpha song and now Knight captures on b3
attacking the bishop bishop goes back to
c7 and now Knight the d4 we have Bishop
to e5 first putting more pressure on the
night here and now Knight eg to e2
adding a defender we've worked a 5
adding now yet another attack to the c5
pawn and here Fabi has to trade to keep
his c5 pawn so we have Knight captures
in c6 b captures on c6 and now look to
a2 as his rook and a1 is under attack
and you also need to keep an eye on the
a3 pawn so Queen to e7 and nakamora just
adds a third attacker to the c5 pawn and
rook the c1 adding a third defender here
and now rook F to a a2 going after the
a3 pawn now so a 4 now that the rook and
the Queen are defending it with Bishop
to f6 now Hicker just makes room for the
e pawn to start marching forward then d4
is coming and it's not not at all clear
how far we will keep this game going
we have rook to a3 by Fabi and now just
a 5
we have night to g3 and now Queen the e6
we have Queen to g6 now painting the
bishop here since the Queen and e6 is
undefended but just d4 now nakamura
starts pushing these central pawns
Bishop to d2 attacks the rook and just
rook captures on a four so far B gives
up the a4 pawn to try and create some
attacking chances rook captures we have
rook captures and now Knight to e4
just getting denied or also into the
attack if you go for Bishop captures on
h6 it seems like you win a pawn but
after night to f8 kicking back at the
Queen you don't really have a good
Square for the Queen this and the this
is taken so once you move the Queen you
just lose the bishop so first Knight to
e4 you add another attacker inter into
the attack of course
and now just night to f8 nakamura kicks
back Fabiano's Queen Queen to g3 and now
King to h7 not having to worry about any
Bishop captures on h6 action in the
future and now look the b1 by Fabi now
he wants to go for a nice rock lift with
rook the b7 or rook to b8 it depends on
what what black plays so rook the a7
camera prevents rook to b7 and now Queen
to d3 threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries after the knight moves so
King back to g8 and only now rook to b8
now pinning the night here with Bishop
to e7 now defending the knight and also
not allowing any night chapters on f6 in
the future and the Queen f3 now it's a
very strong square for the Queen so of
course Nakamura kicks away Queen to f7
and now Queen to g3
again goes for the e5 pawn and again
with some special characters and h6
action happening so Queen back to e6
guarding against both threats and now
rook to e8 pinning this bishop we have
King back to h7 by Nakamura and here
Fabi goes back rook to b8 but here
there is a move for white that is so
good and so complicated that no one
would be able to play it even you if you
pause the video right now I doubt that
you would be able to find it but if you
want I'm not gonna stop you you're
welcome to pause the video and try to
find it it's it's one of the most
difficult moves I've ever seen so you
know do your thing if you must so for
those of you who were able to do it our
congratulations as this is just one of
those moves that no one finds I mean no
one and for those who just want to enjoy
the show its Queen to f3 yes and now it
seems like black is in sort of a sort of
a tutu on there's no good move for black
to be made here and it's very difficult
to make a move for example if you try
something to move the knight let's say
Knight g6 then just Knight to g5 check
wins the game because well you either
win the Queen but you're not even
interested in the Queen because the
black King has nowhere to go the back
rank is covered if you capture with the
bishop you lose the Queen here and if
you capture with the Khan is just going
to h5 mate so you're not moving the
night
you can't move the bishop because the
Queen is under attack if you try moving
the Queen let's say Queen d5 then you
just get rook captures on e7 you just
give up the rook for two pieces capture
scatters and captures and now of course
you still can't capture because of
characters and after the rook attacks
Queen you just go Queen e8 again if
characters you're gonna capture the rook
and the ones the rook moves
Queen rook the b7 or d7 you're just
gonna defend your knife with f3 and you
continue this game having a bishop and
the night for a rook with a better game
for white so this is a like I said one
of those moves that you simply don't
find it's it's there but unless you're
like really focused in you really know
that there are some problems here and
that there's sort of a two-prong for
black you just don't play this so far B
instead went for rook to b8 but now we
have Knight to d7 now the knight can
move we have Queen to d3 again trying
some nasty discoveries and now Queen to
g6 of course preventing this we have
looked to see 8 now putting pressure on
the c6 pawn and there is a there is a
huge threat here for example if if black
let's say makes a move something like
rook to a2 doesn't really matter then
rook captures and c6 is is deadly
because after Queen captures here you
just have Knight f6 check King has to
move as it's a double check and only
only move is King h8 coin cap Queen to
h7 is made so this is a fabi's idea
behind rook to c8 however hikaru the the
you know the puzzle rush genius
immediately spots it and he defends
against it with Knight to a fate but
Fabi didn't realize that night to f8
actually defended against the threat and
here instead of just f3 defending the
knight and continuing the game as Fabi
is better here here Fabi played rook
captures on c6 nonetheless and the
Hikaru just grab that rook and Bobby was
just what what's happening here he
couldn't believe it and now the problem
is the knight f6 check doesn't do
anything because after King he trade
there is no mate tonight coverage the h7
square so after rook captures and c6 he
Karl just grabbed it and now nice the g5
again a double check Fabi tried a few
more moves the knight of seven check
King to g8 and now Knight captures on e5
attacking the Queen
but nakamora just moves the Queen he's
now up a whole rook he doesn't care
about anything
we have Bishop to f4 and now just
blister characters on c5 and it was in
this position that Fabiano Khurana
resigned the game as he is down a whole
rook yeah really really tough break for
Fabi
getting back into the match
again blunder in in a promising position
but yeah that's it's just that the
Hikaru is extremely good in blitz and
some would some would even say the best
as he is now in the finals of the Magnus
Invitational and today we have a Magnus
versus dink to see who will face he karo
in the finals and as Magnus said this is
the first time in in some 10 years that
he doesn't feel like a favorite going
into the match against England so we'll
see what happens there and will he
continue with all the all the Vienna
games and the Kings gambit sand and dh5
or salimos or will we see some some you
know real chess yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it Nakamura is in
the final so we'll see what happens I
would like to thank Vijay sometime
robert Kretschmer Jeff graves sha Chi
Chuan and oven Perez for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video Ciaran
think of for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus invitational until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
heaven I have an excellent rest of your
Saturday and do join us in the elite
chess team battle arena the links are in
the description see you soon